[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire
frédéric mounier publier un livre sur le
siège de paris qui a duré près de cinq
mois en 1870 1871
et oui on l'a oublié aujourd'hui mais il
ya cent cinquante ans exactement paris a
été la dernière capitales européennes à
affronter un siège en règle est la
première à subir le bombardement aveugle
de sa population
imaginez deux cent cinquante mille
soldats prussiens en cercle en 2
millions de parisiens mourant de faim
mourront de froid mais décidé à se
battre jusqu'au bout
c'est dans ce chaos indescriptible
qu'ont été proclamé la république
française et la commune de paris
quelques mois plus tard cette période
particulièrement tragiques de notre
histoire frédéric mounier la
reconstituer en détail dans un livre
palpitant remarquablement bien écrit qui
vient de paraître aux éditions du cerf
mais commençons d'abord par aujourd'hui
comme c'est la tradition dans cette
émission qu'est ce qui caractérise notre
époque voici l'image que vous avez
choisi frédéric ben c'est justement une
image de cette époque là il ya 150 ans
qu'est ce qu'on y voit là bonjour
frédéric ebel écouter on y voit
l'irruption du peuple de paris au palais
bourbon le 4 septembre 1870 et pour moi
c'est d'une certaine façon l'exacte
réplique de l'irruption d'une partie du
peuple américain au capitole le 6
janvier dernier
effectivement et c'est ce qui va donner
la proclamation de la république
on va lui raconter dans un instant c'est
on va les emmener à l'hôtel de ville où
la république sera proclamé on en
affecter le 150e anniversaire l'année
dernière en 2020 et bien commençons
[Musique]
alors on peut comprendre comment la
république a été proclamée et comment
paris a été assiégé pendant 135 jours
il faut repartir de la guerre la guerre
franco prussienne une guerre absurde
dans lequel dans laquelle napoléon iii
va se laisser entraîner il faut imaginer
napoléon iii à sont à l'apogée de son
pouvoir un il vient d'être plébiscité
triomphalement l' empire s'est
libéralisé il a tout l'avenir devant lui
il a réussi la révolution industrielle
en france
la france est riche paris est la plus
belles villes d'europe
et quand je dis l'avenir est devant lui
c'est tout simplement parce qu'il a un
fils qui lui succédera
si tout se passe bien et puis badaboum
il se laisse entraîner dans une guerre
contre la prusse une guerre voulue par
bismarck une guerre que nous allons
perdre royalement j'allais dire
impérialement en quelques semaines un
frédéric mugnier oui on va la perdre
radicalement vous avez raison de
rappeler que napoléon iii était d'une
certaine façon à l'apogée de son pouvoir
impérial en même temps il avait 2,2
points de faiblesse le premier c'est que
quelques mois plus tôt il avait ouvert
son empire à une certaine forme de
libéralisme politique notamment à
travers la personnalité de emile
ollivier
il avait essayé de d'ouvrir la porte à
quelques républicains quelques
républicains tempéré et donc ce n'était
pas du goût de tout le monde et en
particulier pas du goût de ce qu'on
appelait les mamelouks mais mamelouks
étaient les alliés impérialistes
jusqu'au bout des ongles et puis par
ailleurs il faut le rappeler quand même
l'état de santé de napoléon iii c'était
très fortement dégradée il souffrait
d'une vessie d'une gros calculs à la
vessie qui a été exposée et quelques
temps au musée de l'armée aux invalides
et qui le faisait souffrir absolument
horriblement cet homme était incapable
de se tenir debout
incapable de monter à cheval de se tenir
à cheval est incapable de conduire une
guerre et pourtant et pourtant il a
considéré de son devoir d'être à la tête
de ses troupes dans l'est de la france
pendant que sa femme l'impératrice
eugénie assurer la régence et pour lui
ça a été un véritable calvaire
ces journées de guerre ont été un
calvaire
parce qu'il a constaté aussi de ses
propres yeux à quel point ses troupes
étaient désorganisés incapables de mener
une offensive alors qu'en face les
troupes prussiennes et les troupes
allemandes et autrichiennes étaient
unifiés organisé utiliser le chemin de
fer et que tout était prévu jusqu'au
moindre bouton de guêtre ce qui n'était
pas le cas en dépit des déclarations du
ministre de la guerre le boeuf dans
l'armée française alors napoléon
3 face à lui l'armée prussienne une
armée qui a déjà vaincu l'armée
autrichienne qui a vaincu l'armée
danoise et bismarck qui est le la tête
de la prusse veut cette guerre contre la
france parce que c'est le meilleur moyen
d'unifier l'allemagne toutes les
principautés les royaumes allemand
autour de la prusse c'est pour ça qu'il
veut cette guerre 1
voilà c'est un objectif avant tout
politique l'objectif politique est
claire depuis plusieurs années bismarck
a décidé d'unifier l'ensemble des
territoires d'origine allemande que ce
soit la prusse l'autriche et la
multitude de petits et à de petits états
princier qui consisterait qui constitue
l allemagne à l'époque il a décidé de
les de les unifier et c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous le verrons tout à
l'heure il est arrivé à son à son but en
proclamant le 18 janvier 1870 1871 dans
la galerie des glaces à versailles un
lieu très significatif pour lui parce
qu'il s'agissait de prendre une revanche
sur louis xiv car nous autres français
avons oublié mais dans la mentalité
allemande et bien c'est au cours de la
guerre du palatinat que louis xiv a volé
en quelque sorte
l'alsace et la lorraine à l'allemagne et
ça dans la mémoire collective allemande
à l'époque en 1870 c'est très très c'est
encore très frais quoi et donc c'est
dans le la galerie des glaces du château
de louis xiv à versailles que bismarck a
tenu à ce que cette nouvelle unité
allemande ce second reich soit proclamée
alors très vite on l'a vu l'an lempire
s'effondre napoléon iii est pris est
pris et fait prisonnier à sedan il se
rend lamentablement
il avait voulu se replier sur paris mais
mais sa femme l'impératrice eugénie qui
était donc région et 1 et qui a gouverné
la france pendant cet été là c'était et
tragique le lui interdit lui ai dit
attends un bonaparte ne rentre pas
vaincu donc tu ne reviendras que enfin
je sais pas si ce tutoyer mais tu ne
reviendras que vainqueur donc le pauvre
il se fait il est fait prisonnier par
bismarck lempire s'effondre là
la route de paris est ouverte aux
troupes prussiennes l'armée française
n'existe plus et c'est dans ce ce chaos
indescriptible que vous reconstitué
minutieusement dans ce livre que la
république va être proclamés c'est la
foule arrive à l'assemblée nationale
vous nous l'avez montré et de la jules
favre va l'entraîner à l'hôtel de ville
pourquoi est ce qu'il veut la faire
sortir de l'assemblée nationale à ce
moment là alors il faut rappeler il faut
rappeler le contact ce jour là le 4
septembre 1870 c'était un dimanche il
faisait très beau
les parisiens étaient dehors les
parisiens a été sous le coup de la
défaite de sedan pour eux tout à fait
inattendue puisque déjà à l'époque il y
avait beaucoup de rumeurs il y avait
beaucoup de fake news et un bon nombre
de parisiens étaient persuadés que la
guerre pouvait être gagnés par les
français donc les parisiens sont sidérés
et vous avez là une partie de la foule
qui écourte qui est constitué de
républicains radicaux qui sont bien
décidés à nouveau à tenter leur chance
pour prendre le pouvoir de façon
insurrectionnel et révolutionnaire parmi
eux notamment adolphe blanqui et un
certain nombre d'autres révolutionnaires
république qui en février 1848 avait
pris le pouvoir et donc jules favre
voyant arriver cette foule au sein du
corps législatif qui était le nom de
l'assemblée nationale à l'époque jules
favre est léon gambetta qui sont des
républicains disons libéraux qui sont
des républicains parlementaire adepte de
la démocratie représentative pour
utiliser des termes d'aujourd'hui eh
bien ces républicains voient arriver au
palais bourbon une foule disons un peu
un peu composite 1 peut composer à la
fois de curieux de gens qui veulent
simplement fêter la chute de l'empiré
écoutez la proclamation de la déchéance
de lempire et puis au milieu d'eux il y
avait ce qu'on appelait dans les années
70 6970 par ce qu'on appelait des
groupuscules très actif de radicaux qui
eux voulaient proclamer une république
radical est quasiment la commune de
paris
jules favre est léon gambetta cent ans
cela disent c'est pas possible on va pas
laisser faire ça il se souvenait que en
1848 à la tribune de cette même
assemblée
des radicaux avaient pris le pouvoir
avait appelé a déjà créé un impôt sur la
fortune en impôts d'un milliard de
francs pour les riches et hao à aucun
prix ces républicains libéraux ne
veulent voir ce phénomène se rééditer et
donc il faut imaginer le palais bourbon
sans sonorisation avec une foule et donc
c'est celui qui à l'organe le plus fort
qui peut se faire entendre c'est léon
gambetta qui peut se faire entendre avec
gilles fa vous l'avait dit et qui donc
attendez on va aller proclamer la
république certes mais pas ici on va
aller là proclamé à l'hôtel de ville qui
est quand même le coeur battant de la
france républicaine et c'est ce qu'ils
font chacun de leur côté
jules favre part sur la rive gauche sur
la rive droite par dont léon gambetta
par sur la rive gauche et on voit donc
c'est ce flou deux peuples qui va partir
à pied en fiacre qui va partir rejoindre
l'hôtel de ville alors léon gambetta on
s'en souvient il est très jeune à
l'époque quand il a 32 ans il fera
encore parler de lui par la suite
jules favre sas et gambetta il mourra
jeunes d'ailleurs un camp bêta on en a
on se souvient très bien mais au fond il
a une carrière assez courte mais revault
jules favre voudrait qu'on le revoit
parce qu'on l'a complètement oubliée
voilà l'homme en réalité qui va
proclamer la république lui la plus de
50 ans la quelques beaux mois avant il
croyait que c'était foutu parce que l'or
blanc pire triomphait il s'est dit 'ben
nous la république on est déterminés on
n'a aucune chance seulement
et puis pof ils se retrouvent là non
seulement proclamant la république mais
en plus devenant le vice président du
gouvernement provisoire puisque battant
que l' empire s'est effondré il va bien
falloir gouverner et paris et la france
ou du moins ce qu'il en reste et c'est
cet homme là en fait qui va faire tout
le travail
cet homme qu'on a oublié alors on l'a
oublié et c'est cet oubli comme souvent
l'oubli dans l'histoire est tout à fait
injuste
il faut retracer il faut redéfinir cette
personnalité de de jules favre qui était
un homme grand à défaut d'être un grand
homme
à l'époque un homme très très engagé
c'est est ce qu'on appelle un avocat de
gauche qui embrassait toutes les causes
toutes les causes
toutes les causes liées à l'injustice il
avait défendu les canuts lyonnais par
exemple il était très très très très
investi dans cette danse est cause de
lutte contre l'injustice
mais louis napoléon avait décidé il y à
déjà très très longtemps de l'épargné
parce que il avait été l'un des avocats
de louis napoléon lorsque louis napoléon
bonaparte n'était qu'un agitateur parmi
d'autres et lorsqu'il avait tenté dans
les années 1840 de prendre le pouvoir de
façon extrêmement maladroite et donc
jules favre avait tenté de le de le
défendre et donc louis napoléon pendant
son coup d'état
en dépit du fait que je le fais à voir
les prix position donc le 2 décembre
1851 contre le coup d'état de louis
napoléon qui a visé à transformer la
république en second empire et bien
louis napoléon l'avait laissée
tranquille
donc il disposait d'une certaine aura
politique et c'est en s'appuyant sur ce
capital politique qu'il a décidé de
tenter une sorte de va tout et de
proclamer la république au balcon de
l'hôtel de ville est alors à ce moment
là on l'a dit c'est l'impératrice
eugénie qui gouverne la france allait
régente et et vous raconter sa fuite en
fait lempire s'est effondré certains
diront d'ailleurs que les républicains
ont ramassé le pouvoir qui était tombé
par terre y'a pas un élan via la
république comme on en n'avait pu en
connaître comme on avait pu le connaître
auparavant
d'ailleurs le reste de la france n'est
pas républicaine c'est vraiment très
parisien à ce moment là et puis le génie
donc qui est tout seul et vous raconter
sa fuite elle va partir dans une
diligence pour l'angleterre
tout elle elle veut son fils en fait
elle espère jusqu'au bout que le fils
qu'elle a eu avec louis napoléon
bonaparte pourra devenir l'empereur le
malheureux évidemment ne le sera pas il
sera élevé en angleterre et deviendra
napoléon iv dans sa tête mais il finira
tués par les zoulous en afrique du sud 1
voilà alors ce qui s'est passé ce 4
septembre 70 c'est tout à fait étonnant
parce que ce que je vous racontais cette
marche à pied des républicains du
palais-bourbon vers l'hôtel de ville en
fait ça se passait au moment où le génie
était toujours aux tuileries est donc
cette grande manifestation populaire est
passé sous les fenêtres de génie au
génie qui était complètement perdu
complètement
d'une certaine façon hystérique il faut
bien le dire parce qu'elle savait que
son fils était aux côtés de son mari et
que donc son fils était en train de se
dette re capturé par les par les
prussiens donc elles étaient elles
étaient seules mal conseillée elle ne
savait plus quoi faire
et l'attenté de de donner une partie du
pouvoir au général trochut dont on
parlera tout à l'heure qui ensuite
deviendra officiellement le président du
gouvernement de la défense nationale et
puis et puis finalement elle sent que
tout s'effondre autour d'elle elle sent
qu'elle est totalement isolé et donc à
la fin de cette journée du 4 septembre
alors même que le pouvoir alors même que
la nouvelle république est proclamée et
on verra tout à l'heure dans quel
incertitude est proclamée à et proclamé
à l'hôtel de ville et bien elle va
prendre un fiacre avec avec avec sa
femme de chambre elle va errer dans
paris elle va aller du côté des du côté
de la madeleine pour aller voir l'un de
ses amis et puis elle se fait claquer la
porte au nez et puis finalement bas elle
va échouer chez son dentiste du côté de
l'avenue foch
ce elle va échouer dans la salles
d'attentes de son d'anti selva graisser
la patte aux domestiques du dentiste
pour lui permet de rester sur place
et puis le dentiste il a prévu ce soir
là un grand dîner donc il peut pas
annuler son dîner donc elle reste dans
un coin de sa femme de chambre et puis
finalement le dentiste
la rejoint en fin de soirée puis
finalement il va mettre à sa disposition
sa belle voiture de luxe à sa belle
voiture à cheval
et puis ils vont partir sur la route de
cherbourg et son idée c'est d'aller
prendre un bateau pour aller en
angleterre mais elle part doit elle part
dans l'anonymat le plus complet
elle va arriver absolument épuisé non
pas à cherbourg mai à deauville
finalement et puis elle prendra un
bateau une fois arrivée en angleterre
mais ça a quelque chose d'absolument
tragique ce départ alors il eut
heureusement elle avait ses bijoux c'est
ce qui leur permettra de tenir ensuite
un elle avait à plus beaux et belles
collections de bijoux peut-être d'europe
à l'époque
bref nous voilà avec un gouvernement de
défense nationale dont jules favre est
le vice président
gambetta ministre jules ferry aussi
jules ferry les ministres où il est
maire de paris instant là je me souviens
plus exactement
en tout cas on a tous les républicains
tous des élus parisiens puisqu'il n'ya
que des élus parisiens qui sont sûres
sur place qui y forment un gouvernement
et les prussiens qui arrive qui se
rapproche de paris
est ce qu'il ya de formidable dans cette
histoire c'est que le peuple de paris
n'est pas question de se rendre pour eux
c'est pas du tout la fin de la guerre
ils sont persuadés qu'on peut encore la
gagner oui et est donc la question de se
rendre ne se pose même pas c'est pour ça
que ça devient un gouvernement de
défense nationale
il voit là qu'imaginer paris 2 millions
d'habitants plus tous ceux qui se sont
rabattus des départements il ya eu un
premier examen comme en 40
tous ceux qui sont arrivés des
départements déjà envahi par les
prussiens
donc il ya deux millions et demi de
personnes à peu près qui sont prêts à se
battre et à la tête du gouvernement de
défense nationale on met le général
trochut donc on va voir ici en photo lui
aussi on l'a oublié
c'est pas une foudre de guerre c'est pas
un peu ses pages un génie de la semaine
on visse une fumée et s'éteint il
pensait pas qu'ils peuvent gagner est un
général breton
oui c'est un général breton très
catholique qui a hésité à répondre
positivement à la proposition de
l'impératrice eugénie qui voulait lui
transmettre une partie du pouvoir
mais ce qu'il faut rappeler frédéric
taddeï c'est que pendant cet épisode à
l'hôtel de ville
lorsque les républicains arrive à
l'hôtel de ville lorsque gambetta et
jules favre arrive à l'hôtel de ville
l'hôtel de ville déjà occupé est déjà
occupée par les républicains les plus
radicaux qui ont déjà constitué une
forme de gouvernement et qui qui
balancent à travers les les fenêtres ce
qui est l équivalent des tweets à
l'époque c'est à dire des petits papiers
avec des listes de voilà le gouvernement
que nous voudrions constitué et là les
républicains gambetta jules favre et
leurs amis voient le danger ils voient
le danger de l'instauration d'une
république
radical alors même que se sentent que
ils n'ont pas de légitimité et donc ils
se disent sur quoi allons nous asseoir
notre légitimité donc il tente en
quelque sorte un coup de force dans le
coup de force
il décide que après tout eux sont des
élus de la nation puisqu'ils sont des
élus de paris et que donc ils vont faire
un gouvernement entre eux et ils inclus
parmi eux 1
il inclut parmi eux rochefort tête 1-1
journalistes un peu satirique un peu
très très en vogue très très connu et c
est il le met à l'intérieur du
gouvernement
histoire de calmer les ardeurs des
républicains radicaux mais où cette
tension là apparaît dès les premières
heures de la république et dès les
premières heures de la république ce
gouvernement apparaît fragile alors
évidemment il va manifester cette
volonté
belliciste cette volonté guerrière ce
désir de ne pas se rendre parce qu'il
sent que le peuple de paris
au moins le peuple qui voudraient faire
la révolution et ben ce peuple il veut
aller jusqu'au bout pourquoi parce que
ce peuple se souvient de la levée en
masse de ces de 1792 ce peuple se
souvient que l'une des grandes pages
glorieuses de la révolution française
eh bien c'était valmy c'était la lutte
déjà contre les envahisseurs venus de
l'est et donc ce peuple veut se soulever
non seulement pour constituer une
république mais aussi pour lutter contre
l'envahisseur le problème c'est que le
peuple ne le sait pas encore mais il n'a
aucun des moyens de mener la lutte face
à la machine de guerre prussienne oui
c'est vrai que au fond la france n'avait
aucune chance et j'ai presque envie de
dire comme à chaque fois face à
l'allemagne
on a toujours une guerre de retard ce
sera la même chose en 1914 ce sera
évidemment la même chose en 39-40 mai
mais là on est parti véritablement la
fleur au fusil un dans cette guerre
contre les prussiens
ce sera moins vrai en 1914 on pensait
qu'on allait gagner
tout le monde était persuadé de la
supériorité de l'armée française qu'il
n'y avait aucun risque et au fond ce
peuple de paris il croit encore qu'il a
une chance alors il y croit d'autant
plus qu'il est armé et qu' il ya ce
qu'on appelle dans larry est ce qu'on
appelle la garde nationale la garde
nationale est en quelque sorte une
milice composée de
deux citoyens parisiens auxquels on a
distribué des armes et donc ses citoyens
qui pourtant n'ont aucune formation
militaire n'a aucune expérience du
maniement d'armes
une fois en uniforme et une fois armé
ils se sentent tous les courages du
monde
ils savent que paris est défendue par
une ceinture de fortifications que
adolphe thiers a fait construire en 1840
par ce qui chacun se souvenait à
l'époque en 1815 des troupes prussiennes
était rentré dans paris après
l'effondrement du premier empire et donc
paris se sent en sécurité à l'intérieur
de la ceinture des fortifications des
fortifs et paris se sent presque fort
parce que paris est armé parce que paris
est en uniforme et pendant les semaines
qui vont venir et bien on va voir dans
la capitale défilé dé masse imposante de
citoyens qui sont armés et qui demande à
faire ce qu'on appelle des sorties qui
demande à aller au devant des des
troupes prussiennes alors même que la la
stratégie de bismarck et des et des
chefs et des chefs prussiens consiste à
encercler paris et à asphyxier paris à
le laisser mijoter à le crever de faim
de façon à réduire cette révolte
populaire que bismarck sent monter à
l'intérieur de à l'intérieur de paris et
donc on voit là toujours à la fois ce ce
double regard politique et militaire du
chancelier bismarck
il n'y a pas que des fortifications il
ya aussi des forts à proprement parler
il en reste d'ailleurs le fort du mont
valérien et toujours et toujours là sont
et on compte beaucoup sur ces forts qui
ont été construits aussi vers 1840 et
c'est un peu notre ligne maginot de
l'époque on était persuadé d'être d'être
en comble de la modernité et que
l'ennemi ne pourrait jamais fois passé
en fait ils ne serviront strictement
rien
c'est la ligne maginot la première voilà
et c'est juste une fermeture de c'est
juste une fermeture de paris alors vous
avez raison de dire que le mont valérien
existe toujours le fort de montrouge
aussi le fort d'aubervilliers existe
toujours et d'une façon générale il faut
ce qu'il faut se souvenir que cet
épisode du siège de paris s'est déroulée
dans le pari que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui
pourquoi parce que le baron haussmann
avait déjà fait son oeuvre et que le
baron haussmann avait contribué à
urbaniser aéré créer ces grandes avenues
que nous sommes que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui l'opéra de paris qu'on voit
derrière moi eh bien c'était aussi
l'oeuvre de napoléon iii
l'oeuvre d'haussmann et donc le pari
dans lequel s'est déroulé se sont
déroulées ces tensions politiques
militaires dans lequel se sont déroulées
ce drame du siège de paris
eh bien c'est exactement le même pari
qu'aujourd'hui avec en moins la tour
eiffel l'électricité et le métropolitain
et l or quand on se prépare à un siège
quand on se dit prêt à affronter un
siège la première chose à laquelle on
pense au delà des armes nécessaires pour
pour tenir c'est la nourriture et paris
est envahie par les par les animaux on
va stocker des animaux partout pour
pouvoir les manger en fait voilà on va
stocker des animaux on va stocker de la
farine on va stocker beaucoup beaucoup
de choses pour ce pour se nourrir et
puis on va essayer de le répartir de la
façon la plus intelligente possible et
c'est un peu les mêmes difficultés
qu'avec le vaccin aujourd'hui c'est à
dire que le gouvernement avait pas très
à l'aise ce nouveau gouvernement très
fragile qui a peu l'expérience de la
conduite des affaires et bien il n'est
pas très à l'aise on va aussi fondre des
canons on va aussi acheter des fusils on
va acheté de la poudre
il s'agit de comment dire d'articuler
tout ça au sein de cette ville assiégée
au sein de cette ville fragile et au
sein de cette vie qui était elle même
soumise à des temps à des tensions
politiques
c'était vraiment une mission impossible
pour jules favre qui pourtant va
déclarer très vite
nous ne céderons pas un pouce de nos
forteresse nous ne céderons pas un pouce
de nos territoires et tout le monde va y
croire
c'est une proclamation politique un peu
hasardeuse on va vite s'en apercevoir
parce qu'ensuite on va le raconter tout
à l'heure il va les rencontrer bismarck
il
allez presque pleuré dans les bras de
bismarck tellement il se sentira fragile
mais très très vite on s'aperçoit qu'il
ya un espace considérable entre cette
volonté belliciste d'une grande partie
du peuple de paris
et puis les capacités réelles du
gouvernement est alors dernière chose
avant de faire la pause paris n'est pas
encore entièrement encerclée par les
prussiens d'être un partant corps qui
s'en va eh bien écoutez c'est comme lors
du premier conflit à paris qui s'en va
tous ceux qui peuvent partir et tous
ceux qui ont une résidence un
pied-à-terre de la famille des amis en
province et il faut se souvenir que le
second empire a été quand même le grand
moment de l'industrialisation et de la
création des chemins de fer donc il y à
toutes les grandes gares parisiennes
existe déjà et donc tout le monde
tout le monde se précipite dans les
gares pour fuir paris sauf un
victor hugo qui lui exilé glorieux
depuis déjà 1851 à bruxelles à guernesey
jersey bien victor hugo va quitter
bruxelles et j'ai envie de dire
impérialement va rentrer dans paris le 5
septembre il a été acclamé par des
dizaines de millions de gens et il va
vivre tout le siège de paris à
l'intérieur même de la capitale et puis
on a un qui prend le dernier tracé
adolphe thiers et mais ça on va le
raconter juste après une pause
[Musique]
le siège de paris une histoire française
1870 1871
quand le peuple voulait la guerre c'est
le livre de frédéric mounier qui vient
de paraître aux éditions du cfc ce livre
auquel nous consacrons toute cette
émission on est donc au tout début
ou plutôt oui ou tout début du siège on
peut dire le dernier train quitte paris
avec à son bord adolphe thiers adolphe
thiers c'est un personnage extrêmement
important à l'époque qu'il est il est
très vieux il a 73 ans il a été premier
ministre
pas très longtemps d'ailleurs de
louis-philippe pouvez y est ça remonte
et lui il est le seul à 18 500 truies
oui et 10 130 donc et il est le seul qui
a dit on va perdre cette guerre il faut
pas la faire
le seul tous les autres étaient prêts à
aller contre les prussiens lui le seul
très lucide et dit on va la perdre c'est
pas possible
et là on vient le voir et on lui dit il
faut que vous partiez que vous trouviez
des alliés parce que les français sont
seuls à ce moment là et il va partir à
73 ans pour un marathon ce qu'on
appelait à l'époque un marathon
diplomatique puisqu'il va aller à
londres à vienne à saint pétersbourg et
à florence qui est alors la capitale de
l'italie en 1871 il n'y avait pas
d'avion n'y avait pas de train rapide
il avait 73 ans et il va le faire mais
ça va pas marcher
oui alors adolphe thiers est évidemment
une personnalité majeure c'est un tout
petit bonhomme il faut le rappeler il
mesure 1 m 56 il a une voix tout à fait
fluide ce qui dans les assemblées
parlementaires de l'époque comme je le
disais tout à l'heure sans sonorisation
finalement ça incite à écouter il a un
accent méridional très prononcé et il a
bien pris soin de refuser de participer
au gouvernement de la défense nationale
il sentait que la sphère était très mal
orientées et donc il est resté en
retrait mais jules favre a voulu quand
même le l'impliquer dans la sphère et
c'est jules favre qui est venu en
quelque sorte le supplier d'intercéder
auprès des monarchies voisines de la
france pour négocier un cessez le feu
pour essayer de
de négocier la paix et donc le 15
septembre
avec ces trois femmes puisque adolphe
thiers et être igame et bien ces trois
femmes et puis tout son équipage de deux
domestiques il va prendre le train est
derrière lui on va dynamiter le pont de
creil et à partir de ce moment là est
bien la capitale sera véritablement
isolé enfermé et ne pourra plus
correspondre avec l'extérieur si ce
n'est on verra tout à l'heure par ballon
et par pigeon voyageur alors adolphe
thiers vous l'avez dit va sillonner
l'europe en diligence à cheval en train
mais il va se heurter une sorte de deux
murs du coton c'est à dire que les
monarchies sont liés sont liés par des
liens familiaux
on sent que la prusse dispose d'un
pouvoir réel d'un pouvoir diplomatique
réel personne ne veut se mettre à dos
bismarck et donc à dofes tir va être
très bien accueilli partout parce que
c'est un homme remarquable et remarquée
et qui dispose d'une véritable puissance
en europe mais en même temps on ne va
rien lui céder et il va revenir
totalement épuisé trois semaines plus
tard il aura fait trois fois le tour de
l'europe il va revenir absolument épuisé
et sans aucune solution dans la poche
sans aucune proposition de paix dans la
poche et bismarck s'en trouvera d'autant
plus renforcée vous avez dit que adolphe
thiers et et reagan c'est vrai on
appelait ses trois femmes les trois
moitiés de monsieur thiers avec beaucoup
d'humour
oui ce petit bonhomme qu'on voit là bas
ils avaient eu une première fois une
comme maîtresse il avait une maîtresse
ce plus exactement il a épousé sa fille
avec l'accord de sa maîtresse parce que
c'était le meilleur moyen qu'elle avait
trouvé pour qu'il puisse rentrer chez
elles font dépit du fait qu'elle avait à
marie il a donc épousé la fille il a
conservé la mer comme maîtresse et puis
il a pris comme maîtresse la jeune soeur
de sa femme il les a installés tout
étroit avec lui à l'époque c'est de
choquer personne c'était la france on
était comme ça on a peut-être un peu
changé depuis toujours est il que à ce
moment là le siège de paris commence et
le siège c'est là la hongrie mais le
siège ça a été quelque chose
d'épouvantable
philippe frey avec moutier alors il se
trouve que le climat a été désastreux il
a fait très très froid pendant ces
semaines il faut se rappeler que dans
ces immeubles haussmanniens le chauffage
central n'existait pas on voit toutes
les cheminées dans cet immeuble et bien
elle servait à se chauffer très très
vite on a manqué de bois dans la
capitale le le bois de boulogne a été
rasée il a été rasée pour pouvoir
permettre aux canons de tirer sur les
prussiens et pour pouvoir pouvoir se
défendre voir arriver les prussiens mais
en même temps il a été rasée pour
pouvoir avoir du bois de chauffage très
très vite on a eu très froid très vite
la nourriture à manquer surtout le
travail a manqué le peuple est devenu
chômeur
le peuple a eu froid le peuple ne
comprenait pas le peuple était armée le
peuple était en uniforme et il voulait
sortir et donc le gouvernement à
multiplier ce qu'on appelle les sorties
militaire mais tout en sachant que et le
général trochut le savez très bien que
ces sorties étaient vouées à l'échec
parce que ces hommes étaient mal équipés
très vite il bat en retraite très vite
il se heurte à une véritable armée et
donc on voit des sorties qui sont des
échecs lamentables des fuyards qui
reviennent des blessés qui reviennent à
l'intérieur de la capitale le moral de
la capitale à chaque sortie autour de
paris en prend un coup et on rentre
vraiment dans une période extrêmement
noir extrêmement difficile où tout le
monde en veut au gouvernement parce que
le gouvernement ne conduit pas le peuple
vers la victoire que le gouvernement
n'arrive pas à nourrir convenablement la
population puis en même temps au fond
d'eux mêmes
les gens savent bien que c'est c'est au
sens propre
la situation est sans issue donc
vraiment une vie extrêmement difficiles
ce siège de paris a été un épisode
tragique c'est pour çà du reste que
c'est un peu un oublié l'histoire qu'on
en parle pas puisqu'il est entre le
drame de la défaite de sedan et on verra
peut-être tout à l'heure entre le drame
de la guerre civile que fut la commune
alors vous l'avez dit on a des ballons
on va pouvoir communiquer avec le reste
de la france
et pas en tout cas le sud qui n'est pas
que occupé par par les prussiens
il ya en tout 65 ballon qui vont
décoller de paris notamment de
montmartre qui est le l'endroit le plus
haut et et ses ballons ne sont pas un
dirigeable
donc ça veut dire qu'on ne sait pas où
ils vont se poser et vous raconter quand
même un qui va se retrouver en norvège
c'est quand même absolument incroyable
c'est ballon qui s'envole et qui passe
les souvent tiers prochaine on ne sait
pas où ils vont voilà alors là la
capitale a vu se créer un certain nombre
de d'ateliers de fabrication de ballons
notamment la gare qui s'appelle
aujourd'hui la gare d'austerlitz ou
également lag ce qui s'appelle
aujourd'hui le musée d'orsay étaient des
lieux où on a on a construit des ballons
donc il y avait des couturières qui
venait coudre des ballons on a détourné
des conduites de gaz pour pouvoir
chauffer les ballons pour voir leur
permettre de décoller et donc la plupart
d'entre eux ont décollé du pied de la
butte montmartre là du côté de la place
saint pierre de montmartre qui était à
l'époque une étendue à s'est désolé
puisque le sacré coeur n'était pas
encore construit et donc là c'est là que
léon gambetta a pu embarquer à bord d'un
ballon léon gambetta qui était mandaté
par le gouvernement de la défense
nationale pour aller poursuivre la lutte
et il a décollé sans savoir où ils
allaient donc c'était une affaire de
vent c'était une affaire de d'altitude
et puis finalement baïla hatier il
atterrit pas très loin des lignes
prussienne du côté de montdidier au
nord-est de paris un peu au delà de un
peu au delà de roissy puis avec le train
à travers différents moyens
il a réussi à rejoindre autour et puis à
tours il a installé une sorte de
d'antenne du gouvernement de la défense
nationale pour essayer de coordonner
d'une part le retour des soldats qui
avaient été défaits dans l'est de la
france pour tenter de les remettre en
marche pour tenter de coordonner ce
qu'on a appelé l'armée de la loire du
côté d'orléans qui est allé au-devant
des prussiens qui a essayé de faire des
des percées pour rejoindre la capitale
tout ça a été tragique en pure perte
mais ces ballons étaient vraiment un
grand moment d'espoir pour la population
parisienne je crois qu'il faut souligner
le courage qu'il fallait pour mon
l'ansés ballon parce qu'on ne savait
jamais si on allait en sortir vivants
c'est à dire qu'on pouvait être
mitraillés par des prussiens et les
prussiens était très très dure avec les
avec les francs tireurs avec tous ceux
qui n'étaient pas des soldats où on
pouvait finir au fin fond de la
scandinavie est noyée dans la mer
baltique donc c'était une une vraie une
vraie difficulté
et lorsque vous raconter qui est assez
drôle quand on quand on y pense on avait
l'habitude de la guerre sur terre de la
guerre sur mer mais là tout à coup c'est
ballon qui passe qui franchissent les
lignes prussienne bismarck en les voyant
se dit que c'est déloyal
c'est assez amusant en fait c'est la
première fois que au fond dans une
guerre il y avait cette troisième
dimension du ciel qui étaient utilisées
et et est important un grand chef de
guerre comme bismarck à trouver ça
déloyale qu'est ce qu'il aurait dit en
pensant que quelques années plus tard
quelques décennies plus tard les
chasseurs puis les les bombardiers sera
utilisée oui mais ce souvenez-vous il a
fallu quelques décennies pendant la
guerre de 14
ça a été vraiment les balbutiements la
guerre aérienne donc on peut imaginer
l'ébahissement des soldats prussiens qui
eux mêmes étaient extrêmement organisés
obéissez à des protocoles très très
précis on peut imaginer à 7h et
barrissements lorsqu'ils ont vu décoller
ses ballons depuis là depuis la capitale
et puis ces ballons portés des pigeons
voyageurs et là les pigeons voyageurs
ça a été un point essentiel de la du
siège de paris puisque ceux des pigeons
qui ont pu quitter la capitale et bien
ils étaient porteurs de petits billets
on a inventé la micro photographie à
cette occasion là il était porteur de
micro correspondance de mails peut-être
on peut dire à l'époque qui sont arrivés
dans toute la france comme ça et
et ensuite ils sont revenus à paris
porter des réponses et ça c'était le
seul lien qui a pu y avoir entre la
capitale et le reste du pays
eh bien c'était ces braves pigeons
voyageurs c'est vrai que dans ce
d'autant se souvient les images d'epinal
qu'on a conservé de du siège de paris
qui sont rares parce que tu une période
oublié il ya les ballons il y aller il
ya le fait que les parisiens à manger
duras et que on a on a tué découpé et
manger les animaux du jardin des plantes
notamment l'éléphant sont laissons les
rares images qu'on a conservé aux forces
de ce siège
voilà oui enfin il ya il ya eu beaucoup
d'imagés c'est les erreurs images dont
on garde le souvenir à mais les
éléphants du jardin des plantes qui
s'appelait castor et pollux et bien ces
éléphants ont été tués et leur viande a
été vendu inutile de vous dire que le
peuple de paris n'avait pas accès à ces
viandes lac ont été vendues très très
cher car comme dans toute période
difficile il ya eu du trafic de
nourriture du trafic d'alimentation et
les plus riches ont pu presque jusqu'à
la fin presque bien manger quoi que mais
il ya eu aussi des événements politiques
extrêmement difficile le 31 le 31
octobre 1870 il ya une conjonction de
trois nouvelles qui a vraiment contribué
à casser le moral des parisiens d'une
part ils ont appris que la garnison de
metz s'est rendu avec le général baha z
et qui a livré sa garnison de plus de
cent mille hommes aux troupes
prussiennes donc ça ça a été vraiment un
échec absolu
et puis il ya eu aussi une attaque une
tentative de sortie qui s'est faite
contre le gré du gouvernement de la
défense nationale vers le village du
bourget et l'aller les prussiens ont été
surpris et pendant une soirée une nuit
et bien les troupes françaises la garde
nationale s'étaient les francs tireurs
de la presse aussi également ont cru
qu'ils pouvaient lutter à armes égales
contre les prussiens et puis assez vite
assez vite dès le lendemain le village
du bourget a été repris par les
prussiens et c'était la défaite et ça ça
a été quelque chose de dramatique pour
le peuple parisien est donc pris dans
l'étau de ces nouvelles là est bien le
peuple parisien notamment le peuple de
l'ess de ménilmontant 2
belleville avec la sa tête du staff
lorrain ce qui était un personnage
extrêmement haut en couleur et bien il a
pris les armes
les armes dont ils disposaient il a
marché vers l'hôtel de ville
il a assiégé le gouvernement de la
défense nationale à l'hôtel de ville et
il l'a fait prisonnier pendant quelques
heures et donc là on a pu croire que le
peuple le véritable peuples de l'est de
paris pouvait prendre le pouvoir
et puis finalement finalement tout ça
c'est terminé en tergiversation en
palabres ça s'est fini tard dans la nuit
et finalement le gouvernement de la
défense nationale qui était le seul
organe à peu près légitime et bien et
rester en fonction mais déjà ça prépare
la commune qui succédera à ce absolument
de mais ça c'est une autre histoire
il ya des des négociations on sait enfin
le gouvernement de la défense nationale
le général trochut ils savent très bien
qu'on ne peut pas gagner qu'on est
condamné de toutes façons à plus ou
moins longue échéance
un devoir se rendre quand on aura plus
rien du tout à manger donc on entame des
négociations vous les raconter
jules favre part tout seul dans un dans
un fiacre et il va re franchi toutes les
lignes prussienne il va il va discuter
avec avec bismarck
alors il part clandestinement quasiment
sans en avertir ses collègues du
gouvernement de la défense nationale et
sa hantise c'est d'être reconnu au
moment au passage des barrières des
checkpoints qui entourent paris sa
hantise est d'être reconnu par les
gardes nationaux qui très vite pour
effleurer 7,7 quasi traîtrise et donc il
va rencontrer
il va rentrer rencontré bismarck dans
son quartier général qui était établie
dans le château de ferrières à l'est de
paris qui est un magnifique château
construit par la famille rothschild qui
aujourd'hui abrite une école hôtelière
et bien il le rencontre il va avoir deux
séances de plusieurs heures de
négociations avec rothschild mais
rothschild ne va pas céder un centimètre
avec des gens racontent beaucoup et
jules favre le raconte lui-même dans ses
mémoires avec pardon avec bismarck
pardonnez moi
bismarck et jules favre le raconte
lui-même dans ses mémoires qu'il a écrit
quelques mois plus tard et bien il a été
pris d'une crise de larmes face à rocci
face à bismarck part de rang face à
bismarck et bien parce que bismarck lui
a expliqué que ce qu'il voulait c'était
l'alsace c'était la lorraine et que
c'était très difficile pour lui de
laisser s'organiser des élections à
paris alors que jules favre voulait
l'organisation d'élections et bien
bismarck à didon et donc la jules favre
s'est vraiment trouvé pris dans une
impasse
il est revenu la tête basse à paris il a
avoué assez à ses amis du gouvernement
de la défense nationale que sa tentative
de médiation avait été un échec et là
vraiment ils se sont trouvés dans une
dans une impasse absolument tragique
mais au fond dix marques connais bien
les français il a été ambassadeur
de prusse en france quelques années
auparavant
mais là où je dis les connais bien c'est
qu'il est persuadé qu'on va finir par
s'entretuer et c'est vraiment une vision
que les allemands ou toujours eu des
français que les français sont toujours
au bord de la guerre civile et et ça va
se se confirmer dans les décennies
suivantes
mais là à la fin pendant sept pendant
cette ce siège vous l'avez rappelé il ya
deux tentatives de coup d'état
et puis ensuite il ya la commune la
commune va se terminer enfin d'abord va
commencer dans le sens et va se terminer
par la semaine sanglante au moment où
les versaillais de da 9/3 vont rentrer
donc pas rien et donc il est il l'avait
pressenti la ville du mans bismarck
absolument il le savait il savait qu'il
y avait une sorte de bouillon de culture
révolutionnaire dans paris et il faut se
souvenir que la commune a eu lieu sous
le regard des troupes prussiennes qui
était restée cantonnée dans l'effort de
l'est de paris et qu'elles ne sont pas
intervenus et qu'elles ont laissé les
français centré gorges est peut-être
trop heureux de laisser faire ça à quoi
en se disant voilà c'est une sorte de
purge de purges politiques et militaires
qui va permettre enfin tragiquement au
gouvernement républicain d'exister mais
bismarck pendant le siège à jouer sur
plusieurs tableaux
il a reçu aussi un émissaire de
l'impératrice eugénie
il a joué là dessus pour faire croire à
une favre que son gouvernement n'était
pas légitime que d'une certaine façon
une partie de la légitimité pouvait
encore exister du côté de l' empire
enfin bref dix marques a été un
politique très très habile il a toujours
été en situation de pouvoir et il n'a
jamais cédé un pouce à ces républicains
si fragile qui constituait le
gouvernement de la défense nationale
on l'a dit au début de cette émission
c'est paris à ce moment là et la
première capitale européenne dont on va
bombarder la population
tout autour de paris il ya des batteries
de
et
mise en place par les prussiens et il
tire il tire jeudi à l'aveuglent parce
que c'est pas très très précis et puis
qu'il s'agit de terroriser la population
donc on vise la population civile sont
pas des cibles militaires
et lorsqu'elle est intéressant c'est que
les parisiens peuvent espérer que ça va
créer deux d'indignation dans les
capitales européennes et au fond ce qui
indigne le plus laid nos voisins
européens quand il regarde c'est de se
dire mais pourquoi les français sentent
est il à ce point pourquoi les parisiens
plus exactement sentent et il a besoin
il ferait mieux de se rendre alors
bismarck à bien monter son affaire
puisqu'il a fait venir des canons lourds
il a attendu plusieurs semaines pour
faire venir par chemin de fer des canons
lourds depuis l'allemagne les installer
dans l'effort qu'ils avaient investie et
la portée de ces canons lui a permis de
balayer tout le sud tout le sud de paris
le quartier latin le jardin du
luxembourg et les parisiens ont vite
remarqué que ces canons ne frappait pas
au hasard
il frappait on a beaucoup de témoignages
là dessus il frappait des lieux
historiques
ils ont frappé du côté du panthéon ils
ont frappé du côté d'un certain nombre
d'églises qui abritait des blessés et
les français c'est vrai comment dire ont
pris ça à la légère il n'y a eu que 4
100 morts
ce qui était pas beaucoup puisque le
bombardement a eu lieu du 5 janvier au
24 janvier donc voila c'était un
bombardement assez intense mais les
parisiens sont partis sur la rive droite
ceux qui pouvaient ils ont appris à
aller dans les caves pour ce pour se
protéger et finalement il attendait
toujours cette sortie ultime sept
dernières sorties
et finalement en désespoir de cause tout
à fait à la fin du mois de janvier
le gouvernement va organiser cette
grande sortie en masse vers buzenval et
là ça va être une boucherie monde plus
de 100000 parisiens vont se trouver
mal commandé mal organisés mallarmé mal
coordonnés vont se trouver pris dans la
nasse prussienne et ça ça sera le coup
de grâce est là à ce moment là jules
favre et hier vont finalement négocié un
armistice armistice qui conduira donc à
une très grosse indemnité de guerre que
la france va devoir payer à l'allemagne
puisque désormais c'est l'allemagne en
face de nous ça n'est plus la prusse
l'empereur le roi de prusse a été
couronné empereur d'allemagne dans la
galerie des glaces à versailles comme
vous nous l'avez raconté donc on va
avoir une grosse indemnité on va devoir
rendre entre guillemets l'alsace et la
lorraine à l'allemagne puisque c'était
louis xiv qui les avaient conquises et
au fond cette cette guerre franco
prussienne et la matrice de la prochaine
guerre mondiale et mêmes de la suivante
c'est véritablement là que né s'est pas
seulement la république française l
empire allemand qui naissent c'est
quasiment les raisons de la prochaine
guerre mondiale c'est à dire que
effectivement toutes les raisons de
l'amertume et de l'esprit de revanche
sont là réunies puisque l'indemnité vous
l'avait dit et de plusieurs milliards de
francs
il faut quand même rappeler que napoléon
iii avait si bien l'industrialiser la
france que la france a pu payer beaucoup
plus rapidement que prévu au bout de 18
mois
cette indemnité a été payé ce qui a
permis de re stabiliser l'état
économique de la france mais la
tristesse l'amertume et elle il faut se
souvenir de la séance de l'assemblée
nationale à bordeaux fin janvier lorsque
les élus d'alsace et de lorraine ont dû
gilles se sont abstenus devant le vote
qu'ils qui les aurait obligés à
entériner la perte de l'alsace et la
lorraine
c'était une blessure absolue et ensuite
des générations de jeunes hommes ont été
élevés dans le culte de cette fameuse de
cette fameuse revanche et il faut se
souvenir que une fois l'armistice signé
et bien bismarck avait obtenu de la part
du gouvernement français que les prix
siens pouvaient
et filer une dernière fois sur les
champs-elysées et là on a vu
fin janvier les troupes prussiennes
défilé sur les sur les champs elysées et
juste après eh bien il ya eu une sorte
de de célébration de dédiabolisation de
l'arc de triomphe qui a été enfumé pour
faire oublier les vapeurs méphitique et
des troupes prussiennes qui avait défilé
sous lui à la grande honte des parisiens
il ya il va y avoir des élections
législatives organisées avec la corde
bismarck ces élections législatives vont
être remportée par adolphe thiers tiers
va se retrouver chef du pouvoir exécutif
il deviendra par la suite le premier
président de la république de la
troisième république
mais à ce moment là il ya une sorte de
scission puisque jules favre va devenir
ministre des affaires étrangères du
gouvernement de tiers mais il ya aussi
une partie qui refusent toujours cet
armistice qui a donc été qui avait donc
été négociée avec bismarck et ça ça va
donner la commune de paris là ce sont
les les radicaux qui prennent le pouvoir
et
et ça va donner alors ça va être dur et
très très peu de temps mais c'est là
c'est à dire que jules favre
oui jules favre a commis une erreur
tragique c'est qu'il a négocié auprès de
bismarck pour que les parisiens puissent
conserver leur arme et donc d'une part
tous les parisiens ont été armés dans
cet esprit d'amertume de revanche et de
tristesse que je décrivais est par
ailleurs et bien les fameux canons que
les parisiens avaient payé que les
parisiens avaient payé de leur argent
qui avait été fondue pendant le siège de
paris
et bien c'est canon il était toujours à
l'intérieur de la capitale et notamment
il était toujours place wagram
aujourd'hui et puis ils ont été amené
sur la butte montmartre et c'est là que
il a suffi de quelques épisodes
désastreux pour mettre le feu aux
poudres
le peuple de paris a exécuté
sommairement deux généraux et ensuite on
est parti dans la vrille de la guerre
civile qui était et compréhensive du
point de vue de la psychologie
collective puis ensuite le gouvernement
de la commune a éprouvé toutes les
difficultés du monde à asseoir son
autorité à construire son pouvoir
militaire a diffusé son sa vision de la
république à travers le pays et donc
tout ça c'est terminé dans un bain de
sang absolument tragique il faut jamais
oublier que ce fut véritablement une
guerre civile à la française et d'une
façon générale je crois qu'il faut pas
oublier non plus que les épisodes
révolutionnaires en france sont souvent
suivis d'épisodes autoritaire n'oublions
jamais que le premier empire a succédé à
la révolution que le second empire a
succédé à la république libre et
fraternelle de 1848 et que finalement
eh bien c'est la république qui au début
la troisième république qui était quand
même autoritaire qui a succédé à 7,6
triste commune et le paris qui sort de
là c'est un pari alors vous le disiez
c'est le pari qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
à c'est le pari de haussmann qui est
assiégée et qui ensuite lors des deux à
la fin de la commune qui est en partie
incendiée par les communes heures alors
ils ont bon goût ils incendient plutôt
les trucs les plus moches 1
que personne ne regrettable par la suite
mais il faut bien voir que de toute
cette affaire
je suis enfin ils ont incendié le louvre
non mais ça ils ont incendié le louvre
110 ont incendié le conseil d'état oui
je parle de dette des bêtes le loup
leçons et se redire en raison de la
bravoure du du directeur du louvre quand
même un nom une grande partie de paris a
été brûlés volontairement par les
communards c'était une perte tragique en
est à tel point même que va se il va y
avoir un tourisme
ensuite on va venir voir les ruines de
la de la ville lumière de la plus belle
capitale de l'europe
on va venir de tous les pays voisins
admirer les ruines y aura des cartes
postales qui vont être envoyées partout
ne trouve encore aujourd'hui de tous les
bâtiments incendiés
je vous remercie frédéric mounier
d'avoir passé toutes ces temps avec nous
le siège de paris
merci bonsoir française 1870 1871
quand le peuple voulait la guerre c'est
paru aux éditions du cerf ce merci de
nous avoir suivis et rendez vous au
prochain numéro
[Musique]